nah northern Washington State so there's
like almost no Sun and the winner the
Sun doesn't go above the trees because
the trees are so huge so my my roosters
have been crowing at the moon
you know I did uh I was doing this joke
about my red pill rooster how he's
always trying to wake people up about
the moon landing
and lately he really has been crawling
at the full moon it's because it's
brighter than the Sun in the winter here
it's kind of fascinating huh you you
guys are two hours behind because now
over here the Sun is setting you guys
still got some light some daylight over
there yeah but it never really kicks
like our trees in the Pacific Northwest
is so big that it never really gets
above the trees and so um I totally
understand you know you do get some
seasonal affective disorder but
fortunately I get to be outside so much
that uh you know I I don't I don't quite
go I don't quite feel like Kurt Cobain
it's a big difference for people because
we I think many people now they become
domesticated so living in the concrete
jungle and now yeah and indoor indoor
cats indoor cats yes indoor cats you
know you get you don't get to see or
feel God in those environments I was
just talking to my buddy earlier on an
earlier stream today about how he used
to live in the city and had the fancies
in the Laozi's and now he lives on a
hundred acres you know he's got a
homestead everything and it's like we're
having this conversation about how in
the cities it's almost intentionally
they're always over stimulating and
jarring and shaking you so that you
don't get to see any element of God it's
always just like this weird distortion
where you don't get to see like the
handiwork you know like that the the
beauty of it and so I think like that's
one reason why rural people have a more
sense of the creator than city people
because I think in cities the man-made
noise and distraction just keeps
people's eyes and I'm nonsense I was I
was interviewing someone a brother by
the name of Hamza sources and he was
talking about he was quoting some book
and in the book he was he that the book
that he was quoting was talking about
trees and the ways trees communicate to
each other
it was just mind-blowing did you know
about this the way so AB you chop if you
cut down a tree like they'll release
their nutrients to their brother trees
it's amazing like oh it's fascinating
and my brother's a lumberjack so I used
to do that stuff and we were like
learning about that together and we had
these like waves of guilt because of how
you know just how intricate their
relationships are and how they have
almost families I mean they're not
sentient in the same way but they also
kind of are you know it's it's it's just
a beautiful existence man you you
comment commented on something and
actually you got a fan in in Bosnia his
his name is Orhan so say hello to Orhan
are you man and he sent he sent me a
video and in there you were talking
about the beats you were talking about
it was in one of your videos about 21
minutes into it he said check this out
I think Owen cracked the code and I'm
paraphrasing what you were saying you
were talking about how through the
musical instruments how they're able
because we're emotional beings and
they're able to open you up with the
music and then put the male malware in
you and then inject you with what with
whatever they want and you're not even
just thinking you subconsciously you're
not even thinking that I that I
understand it correctly oh it's 100% hey
you know it's like I was talking to a
friend recently about how the eyes are
the windows to the soul that's almost
like a a double thing where you have to
protect your eyes it's like it's like
the malware is a perfect way to describe
it where they're trying to trigger these
base emotions like the beat like your
mother's heartbeat like to do do you
know and then the different chord
progressions and then the 12 notes and
the 13th notes and the seventh and the
12 beats all that and so you start
opening up but then that's when they can
Trojan horse you with all this nonsense
and the more I learned about Tavistock
and how as a musician how much stuff and
I've been on this for a while but I
didn't quite get it until very recently
where I would
these Coldplay songs are all nonsense
but yet they'll make people cry and weep
and sing along to words that have no
meaning and how you know music is a way
to just open people up to nonsense and
and yeah I found that fascinating where
there really is like like codes and and
that's why people should be really
responsible about what they listen to
and what they watch because you know you
can watch some of these Hollywood movies
that you know same with pornography
you know pornography is putting malware
in people and it's in it's in it's uh
you know when you're either like false
arousal or false
you know hero triumph all this stuff
that you're watching you instinctively
start going okay okay and then from
there they'll just plant nonsense in you
and you know the media I mean Muslims
know this more than anybody about how
the media can demonize good people and
uh like over time you start or you know
I think that's the real Road people the
real split in the road where people are
like okay now that we understand the
spell that was 9/11 and the spell that
was all this stuff what do we do now
you know do we ever listen to them again
or do we like analyzed it and understand
like what it was and like how many
innocent people got killed and like
that's the type of stuff that I've been
really interested in lately is just like
you know so many people are now awake to
the manipulation and the malware and
stuff but yet they aren't quite facing
it that like you can't trust the media
and until either boogeyman that they've
created or not really the boogeyman you
know I like Russia Russia clusion or
like Muslim like Muslim extremism or
like all this stuff or you know the the
Christian version would be these people
in a Texas called the Westboro Baptist
Church that will throw away blood on
soldiers and stuff like they put malware
in you so it just separates you from you
know the humanity of all of us and how
the world really isn't as violent or
degenerated as we think it is and you
know because trauma will make people
slaves you know because you think all
day like how many times
do you really see someone like beaten or
raped her kidnapped or whatever but in
our minds it's just constant because of
Hollywood and because of media and I as
your Bosnian friend said I really am
trying to crack these codes you know
that was interesting yeah the reason I
because we often say that we're aware
the STDs you know the sexually
transmitted diseases but the spiritually
transmitted diseases they can get you
with a lot of this this music that's out
there you know people if you just took
away the beats and they just gave you
the lyrics some of the sick things of
profanity not just a pornography of you
know some very violent sick things
demonic things dark forces that are out
there that they're using these
instruments you know to get into the
hearts and minds of III did a program
out there where I was asking some of the
youth there was this bubble garelli
they're very very and it's crazy like
how popular these guys are so we went
out and asked people hey how you doing
do you listen to Baba Carelli and they
said yeah we listen to me I say so what
do you think what kind of message do
they push out positive-negative they're
like oh is it a good message he said no
I said do you think it's upgrading women
or degrading women probably degrading
women all of the negative things then
then the light bulb goes on I think and
I was like do you really think you
should be listening to this and they
were like no not really
as if people are don't know how almost
simple it can be to snap people out of
their spell yeah cuz you can what I want
what I'll send you this you can watch
you can see the reaction they're like
it's just amazing no that's like that's
why people like us are so demonized a
lot of times is because spells that
they've worked and they're literally
spells that they've worked a decade on
to keep people in this dance of nonsense
this demonic nonsense and all it takes
is just like hey man have you thought
about what Titanic is really about you
know like why'd she throw that in the
ocean not give it to her granddaughter
like does that mean she's kind of
selfish you don't like just little
things like that people like hey do you
think Caitlyn Jenner's Woman of the Year
but Caitlyn Jenner
been a woman for a full year you're like
yeah that's weird yeah yeah you know
it's like 1 times for action at 1 is
less than 1 like stuff like that and
then they just like what I found is how
many men have just never been told to
not watch porn where it's like oh that's
a weapon against you that's gonna that's
planning demonic seeds and it's made to
cook you and it's made to lower your
population are you still gonna watch it
and they're like no it's like their
whole lives they just go and not one
person is like what are they saying in
this song like you really really think
we all live in a yellow submarine er you
think we shall go to a club and like
just get a random woman and just violate
her it's like now that you put it that
way I can't listen to it the same way
you know I I take it as a compliment
every time someone says that I ruined
something for them I mean there are you
ruined porn
good how many I hurt I hurt porn makes
more than all of the sports all of the
put them all together basketball
football hockey all of these avenues
they make so much revenue but you put
them all together the porn industry
makes more than all of them yeah and you
also have to wonder like all the free
porn who's back in that and why because
you know when I found out that Israel
would pump free pornography into
Palestine that's what really really
really I knew I once I really I started
realizing that there was something wrong
with porn once I started having a family
and I just couldn't make those
connections like how can I watch this
and have this and then when I realized
the history behind it and how it really
does it's used as a weapon against men
you know that's when I was like oh this
is bad and then when you see just a
millions of hours of HD footage that
require all this server space and all
this stuff and how easy it is to access
and how like a guy like me is not a
anymore yet you can have porn I'm like
what is this and then I realized that
when you are sexually engaging with
these images it really is
demonic experience like now it makes it
so men can't like criticize bad things
in society because you're looking at
really degraded women Runaways drug
addicts and it's it's just like they're
being exploited in these scripts that is
made to give men you know a sense of
almost femininity like they're almost
become like yeah like cocked and it's
like and now that I see like Rolling
Stone saying that no not November is a
right wing conspiracy and I'm like oh
they're pushing this so hard like I just
think like put young man who was that
I'm not what's that no before you said
who was pushing it they you know and
some day I go in and out of who they is
you know in the end of the day some name
some name before that on the magazine
that was like you know that's globalist
media but it's like I still you know I
get the hubris sometimes where I think I
can figure out which groups are pushing
what all that and the end of the day
it's just demons you know it's just it's
just uh as the Muslim heard of the devil
as the envious one yes so I would say
that we can we say where you have you
have what we believe you have the the
devil you have a beliefs Lucifer or
whatever you call him and then you have
his forces the dark forces right the
evil forces and then when people don't
have the Creator in their life we didn't
have a connection to God to guidance
then the moral compass is off that's why
you started oh toxin yeah you just you
have no armor like you it's it be it
becomes so difficult to not have that
that base at all they just kitty by
wolves and it's like more people are
waking up to this and you know that's
why I like me and you can be friends all
this because it's not as much about
specific theology at least in my opinion
is it is fear of God belief in God the
One God and like understanding that
that's the rock that you can walk on and
then from there build family speak truth
all that and that way you can kind of
see what I call grab Wars rather it's
Muslim grab Wars Jewish growls crazy
grabbers atheist grabbers like the
people that are spinning lies in order
to like well you know grabble i think
that we're all in this together you know
i mean yeah this is important because
now you you give people something to
think about you know because I believe
in a there's their sign they don't test
I mean there was an Oxford University
study that they done this is this is a
university that's not a religious base
and I believe it was like two points
five or more million dollars were they
they had so many scientists and and they
concluded that the belief in God is
innate and I don't know yeah you've
heard of this god they called the god
spot so now when you talk about these
things when you talk about God this is
something that you know lights up in the
human being and we call that the one who
covers this he does what's called you've
heard this word cool foot coffee the one
who covers this is like the farmer
covers up the dirt right right and this
is you cover up the truth you you fight
against what's intrinsically inbuilt in
you you cover this up and you go against
that and you justify yourself you'll
press yourself so I mean dirt yeah
that's that's definitely a bummer
anybody my dirt and doesn't let my
carrots grow yeah yeah yeah now the
older I get the more I see how sin gives
people veils in their eyes like they
truly don't see mmm if you engage in too
much of that I know people that I like
that I think are good people that are
constant engaging and not in not if you
know there's like the hatred of God type
people that are like immoral versus
amoral which is people that are just
kind of like indifferent and he mystic
those people that a lot of them I I
really care about they can see in their
eyes they don't see things like that
they literally like the more sin that
engage and the more there's there's like
these invisible veils that go over their
eyes and they literally don't don't see
things and I'm just slide it's it's
really mind-blowing mmm how the like the
more above you know cuz we're all we're
all have sin in our lives on some levels
we fight against you
but like the more you reject that the
more you you're allowed to see things
it's really fascinating and that's
literal like I see people that don't see
things like that they're just like and I
might and they're not evil they're not
like trying to subvert me they just
don't see obvious realities in life like
they don't see you know that someone's a
deceiver or like something bad is
clearly coming in the next two months in
an area and I'm like how are you not
getting water and they're just saying
lollipops
it's weird it's a spell yeah going off
there what you're talking about the what
what we're taught is that in Islam that
every time a person does a sin this
leaves a black spot on his heart so now
through repentance remembrance of God
this gets a race but imagine a person
continues to indulge in the worst of
things and now the blacks throw out
another black spot another then the
heart becomes totally black and blind
now and the only antidote for that is
again turning back in repentance turning
to the crater you know seeking his
forgiveness his mercy and and his
remembrance and remembering our
departure date we're gonna die from this
light this is supposed to be a hard
softener because we often remember our
bee days birthdays but too many people
make a joke about it they don't want to
talk about it but people don't take
thinking about the DD I call it the
departure date because that is supposed
to be a hard softener to really humble
you to remember hey we're gonna leave
this light behind you know all this
wealth and everything we've accumulated
pretty soon you're gonna have to say
bye-bye so that should help you to
motivate you to think about what's my
purpose in life why am I here why I've
been created yeah and I think my goal
always and I can usually attain this his
work so hard that death not only doesn't
scare me
I like 10% of me is like that sounds
like really good sleep you know it's
like I start working before the Sun's up
and I'm not done to the Sun after Suns
down so I don't really have that much
idle time or any time in my day to
really think about that I just hope that
like when
when my time comes like I've locked some
good trees and some good stop find my
family but the idea is like well like
what you talk about is being being what
term you want to use awoken awake you
know people are sleeping and then the
reality hits and then it's too late like
you know that life is not all about just
accumulating wealth materialism you know
porn and music and entertainment
everything out there just distracting us
you know from the reality yeah just a
big distraction and the beauty about the
about the creator and about truth is the
antidote spreads really fast that's why
they have to have so much control over
media and and music in school and
pharmaceuticals and war and all this if
you have someone just pointing out the
obvious
I remember here's an example from my
life I was on a TV show and we were
touring to promote the show and we're at
the front row like a Yankees game and
one of the guys on the show the student
mad he wanted a picture of him you know
with the field in the back and he turns
to one of the guys in the in the row
behind us he's like hey okay can you
grab a picture of me and the guy just
goes of just you and he was like yeah
yeah and and my body didn't even really
understand but the guy was like alright
and it just dawned on me what it's like
so many people don't even think about
how most people don't ever take a
picture of just them like the selfie
culture is so weird and if you just have
one grown man be like well I do want a
picture of just yourself it's just
that's over like I just immediately
snapped out of that zone where I'm like
yeah that's weird and I think the more
people just speak honestly the more and
the less fear people have the more that
we can just try and do our best here and
and heal from the black spots that that
are on our hearts you know you talk
about fear did you hear about not too
long ago this is one before I left for
my trip but there was a story American
Airlines there was two Muslims who were
waving at each other
and then from there one went to the
bathroom and the report went that he
flushed the toilet twice so I saw so the
the crew put this together like very
suspicious there waving flushing the
toilet twice they they pulled the plane
back
they got him off they got him off and
they ended up interrogating him for like
a couple hours and then they let him go
and then they had to get on a new flight
and all that so when you hear stuff like
that I mean what do you what are you
thinking well if I was that Muslim I
would just laugh I know that's probably
uh
unbelievably enough but like that's like
six foot eight so I run in the morning
in the woods a lot with my dog and the
other day I was I was running and maybe
being a giant is somewhat like being a
Muslim in these times but like I was
jogging through the woods and this woman
was walking with her husband and she
just turns and screams she was like it's
all good you know cuz i n't person and
if i was and i kind of got a kick out of
that but it's like if i was muslim i
probably laughs it's just the idiots
that we're just like so scared when
really what they should be scared of is
what they're eating and what they're
watching you know the real fear on a
plane is that little black mirror right
in front of them you know or they're
just watching horror that's one reason
why i almost died trust muslims more
than a lot of people these days is
because there's so much negativity about
them from the past 20 years because
they're like trying to justify these
wars that like i don't know there's just
something i trust about those guys just
like to make it through that and still
have a smile on your face and i have a
family I'm like that guy's a good guy
you know because no one's propping them
up like no one's boosting up like a lot
of Muslims in America because god forbid
anyone have compassion for the countries
that are currently being bombed for
poppy seeds you know copies do you think
this is a deliberate attack now on the
family traditional family values the
family the family is Deen number one
threat to
the slave masters of man like I'm a you
know that the family is what can resist
so they're trying to create the sexual
liberation where people are now thinking
that it's somehow good to have sterile
sacks and extending the adolescence we
criticize someone in their 20s and
people are like he's Justin in his 20s
he's just a boy you know all this stuff
and then the school pushing you know all
this like transgenderism and
homosexuality and stuff it's all to
destroy the family all of it it's all
just like the last thing they want is a
man and a woman to have a stable
grounded family because those people are
less likely to be tricked and bullied
and enslaved mm-hmm what do you there
was a video that was out I don't know if
you got to see it it was I don't know if
this was a I don't know how it even to
define it was it a what do you call it
there was a male or female I'm not sure
and she was simulate he was she was
whatever what are we gonna call it that
this individual was simulating like they
were pregnant they had their belly full
yeah like they were pregnant and then
she started stabbing the it was all fake
but she was stabbing like she was
pregnant and she pulled pulled abate
child out with the placenta everything
started to like cannibal cannibalism
like eating it and and and and what was
more scary was this was all under like
the probably the preach sex art right a
showbiz show but the people in the
background are like you know clapping
and you know then seem like nobody would
discuss did you see this video no man I
stay away from a lot of that stuff
anyway here's one thing that'll never
happen in the country that's all I'm
guessing I was like in the city right I
was like a this was at a bar somewhere
but I just could not I could not imagine
I I was like this is something that now
the world is coming together I can
imagine people get upset for someone
praying in a park you know somebody you
know maybe a woman emulating Jesus
mother Mary people go like why you know
for some stupidities nonsensical things
but this is some I mean seriously I mean
for this is something out
just flabbergasted to think like why
there was more media coverage to be
brought some kind of uh outcry against
this well that's the thing like because
the media is compliant in all this they
like this stuff they don't want to fight
this they want horror and it's like the
good news is you know it's talking about
this is my buddy earlier today that the
devil's jump the shark you know where
it's gone so far that it's having the
opposite effect where you know so many
people are not being lulled to sleep
anymore with this lazy river of hedonism
you know it's one thing to be like oh
yeah gay people just want to be married
okay look once you start being like okay
that's someone stabbing a baby like
that's a pregnant girl stabbing herself
and mock and mimicking like eating the
baby people are like okay I'm gonna
start praying to God and I'm gonna stay
away from bars and like that's what
happened to me I never thought I was
gonna homeschool my kids you know I was
like yeah you know I got beat up a lot I
got a lot of fights for like you know at
school as soon as they started teaching
sodomy and stuff it's like I can't send
them to school now so now we're gonna
homeschool and that's one thing about
Muslims I think a lot of people are
starting to respect a lot is a lot of
those families are the only ones
standing up to the curriculum in England
you know you have all these British
people and they're not saying anything
another teaching sodomy to
seven-year-old and then you have some of
these Pakistani families that are like
actually protesting it saying don't
teach that to my kids and I think a lot
of more conservative minded people are
gaining respect for that you know yeah
so what kind of message are you trying
to send now is this I'm trying to
understand I just can't get it it's like
okay is this a message saying that the
woman say this is my body I can do as it
as I wish this is pushing abortion like
what what's the message behind of
something like this this kind of there's
no message it's pure demonic chaos it's
like what could the message the message
is just a hatred life it gets to a point
where you know it doesn't even appeal to
the sensory or like the senses of the
human anymore like there's a time when
you can appeal
Pence's of life promiscuous sex or you
know drinking or going out or indulging
and like fancy things and make women
want you except when you're miming
stabbing a pregnant woman and eating the
baby that's like to the point where it's
like you've committed your like in the
wrapper be like you're you you've given
yourself over to like pure darkness and
when any one witness is that they're
like that's awful like that's almost
like these people are now paying for all
the steps that probably felt good to get
there where it's like now they're just
it's like a ritualistic hatred of people
yeah and that's clearly I mean when you
see like material evil like that it's so
hard to not to not also see God where
you're like well if that's real then
there must be something else because I
just saw my son giggle where it's like
and I see that it's like okay I now see
good and evil like obviously I'm not
gonna be tricked by fancy pants and
lollipops anymore you know how much do
you think now because we see this a lot
of these things growing at such a rapid
rate when you look you go and you
investigate and you look at you know
some scholars in Islam they'll talk to
people who have gone down this route and
they'll give their individual
experiences and they might have
interviewed 50 60 70 people and when
they talk to them the the route is
something in their childhood they got
molest something happen yeah I know in
their life and you know that you dig
deeper and then the next guy says the
same thing next guy says the same thing
it's like this is science now now you're
collecting some some good data and now
you add to that let's say you add to it
I mean chemicals and foods you know you
add to that trauma and the family does
that any other again this doesn't
justify something but you start to look
like what all these components coming
together you following me you know I
think right now I mean this comes back
to the destruction of the family like
everything like all the evidence you're
now listing comes down into a breakdown
and we give you these ours in these
these
and beginning events will start
manifesting in people so I think a big
part of it is a father that isn't
representing God properly in the home
rather he's like cocked or absent or
abusive or selfish or materialistic or
whatever that because when you look at
so many of these like real proud a
theists like the Four Horsemen of the
Atheist apocalypse like Sam Harris all
these guys every one of them to the man
has either no dad or a real bad dad and
then from there if you have a
molestation component now you're looking
at someone rewiring someone's brain
sexually in a in a destructive way and
then and then when you have all the
reinforcements of society you can see
where it all comes from in the in the
root the base is family because when you
have you know a strong family and a
strong faith and a strong community you
can be hurt you can be attacked you can
be messed with and and come through it a
lot better than if your home you know
like your home base is hurting you then
you grow a real resentment of your
father and then a resentment of God
because your father is the ambassador of
God in your home when you're a young
child like you you don't understand God
in the same way so it's like your father
will protect you and honor your mother
and if he fails then you hate your
Creator and and and that's because it's
like I was never immoral I didn't have
that like I hate people or anything I
just was like I like women and partying
and you know I was just more selfishness
we're seeing a rise in people that
clearly hate you know life like they
hate this and so they're acting out in
these symbolic ways of like you know the
hatred of children the celebration of
abortion then my the art of stabbing of
baby like that that's that's from some
real trauma the more we expect our kids
and expose them to the media trauma the
school trauma the nutritional trauma
they will also hate you know creation
and and that's what and I think you're
right about that like
almost every homosexual I know - the man
was molested as a kid you know were they
some some male introduced sexuality to
them when they were still forming and
now they're in this state and that's and
that's why it's so important to protect
our children I was why there was a
documentary showing people going down
that path and then getting the getting
certain things addressed from their past
yeah
and coming coming out from this but not
being embraced in a way like with
congratulations from their community
they were like no no once you're here
you got to stay here there's no going
back you know to the natural way the way
that God intended us the way that the
Creator intended us to be like you know
so this is this is this is uh
interesting yeah like misery likes
company you know the whole LGBT thing is
like they don't want each other to be
happy they want them drunk on a
Wednesday during the day in a bar
looking for a stranger to hook up with
like if you address the shame a lot of
it has to do with shame like if you
addressed the shame from your past and
the hatred of your past you really can
grow out of just about everything and
wet and that's one of the biggest
threats to the these communities is that
people can grow out and be like I don't
want to live like that anymore I don't
want to be in these abusive crazy
relationships and hate myself and be a
drug addict and all that and then when
people do that you know the the
community that they were just in they
they're hated for it yeah because it's
like proof of life it's like proof that
that soul doesn't die and it can be
healed that the black spots that you
were talking about can over time be be
healed and they don't want anyone to
know that you know like my comedy
community from Hollywood when I you know
and I never attacked them but like when
I you know was could start living a more
moral life like a lot of those people
like hated me for it because they were
basically just like how
dare you leave our layer of hell and I'm
just like don't we all want this you
know hmm what when you are when you
think about all the things from your
from your past and someone could have
been through so much trauma and drama
but now you you you you get to
experience a better life it's like you
can go and be at that bar and simulating
you know cannibalism and you know
stabbing a child and some next sick
individuals gonna take it to the next
level and you do have people sacrificing
kids you have the pedophilia rings and
all this crazy stuff that's out there
you can continue down that Rob because
everyone has a choice now right you you
can go ahead and and go towards
something that's a healthier for the
heart for the soul for it for you for
you in this life and the next life or
you can continue on this crazy demonic
way so you still have a choice while
you're alive you can change everyone can
change for the better if there's never
yeah you can always change for the
better it's so true and it's like and we
as men don't have we don't say who is
damned and who is it that's that's a
real that's a real problem that I see
that people are it's like oh this
person's gonna howl or this person's
damned it's like I I really I don't ever
do that because I we don't get to decide
that all we get to do is not try to help
each other get out of hell you know
there's a story an interesting story
from from a tradition of about the man
who killed 99 people have you heard it
good ha can I share it with you cars it
just shows the mercy of God Almighty
where there was a man he had killed 99
people and then he went to this this
monk and he asked them look because he's
having Restless sleepless nights
it's just overtaking him it's consuming
him right he's not feeling good about it
obviously so he goes to the monk he says
hey what can I do the guy said you
killed what 99 people you're damned
you're done right you're going to hell
and he killed it so he kills him too he
kills him so some time later the guy
also again he starts you know looking
for salvation for help you know what
should I do
so he goes to a learning management
yeah he asked him like you know what
should I do I kill hundred people he
said listen you need to do so you need
to repent you need to turn to your
Creator you need to get out of this
place where you're at right you need to
leave this town
this shows the the people you're around
how they influenced you right
so one he established him you know
connection with his creator turned to
the all loving the most merciful and get
hit hit the road get out of here right
because you know you're gonna keep
falling in the same traps right if you
say if you livin in Hollywood you got to
get out of Hollywood you've been there
so anyways now as soon as he leaves the
place where he was at he he dies he was
very close to where he left so now the
angel of punishment comes and the angel
of mercy and I quoted we get what are we
gonna do now so city so they go to to
the to God Almighty and he said measure
wherever he was closer to if he was
closer to the town he was going to
that's towards my mercy I'm gonna grant
him paradise right I'll forgive him if
he was closer to the town that he just
left then I'm gonna go then you you take
him to Angel punishment because we
believe there'll be angels the
punishment they're gonna come so now God
Almighty made the distance he made the
distance longer and short shorter to the
place he was going so now the place that
he was heading to it was closer and now
he forgave him so see it shows the mercy
of the Almighty
so yeah moment when he chose to walk
away from his town even if it's just two
steps
I went from what I gather God was like
well that shows intent that shows that
you were taking action to leave and you
wanted to leave your your how much
existence and he took mercy that's a
that's a great story
yeah so this just was just just
illustrating uh you know the fact that
there is hope for everybody everybody
can go ahead and change their ways and
whatnot well what do you think about now
when I'm call me just old-fashioned I
don't know we're probably maybe about
the same age but you know you can at one
point when I was growing up it was very
easy
to identify you know you have a boy boy
parts girl girl parts nowadays with this
whole thing you know the her bursar your
what's going on here one oh it's all
it's all nonsense it's it's it's all
just trying to destroy the good the
beautiful and the true
you know it's trying to just one of my
buddies boxers always talks about how
like you know the answer is to genders
so the devil wants anything except for
the truth so 3/5 2100 doesn't matter oh
just just one or two think about what
you're talking before like my comedian
brain the way my brain always works is
uh if I was to tell that as a joke I'd
be like a man said he killed 99 people
and said well you're you're damned
you're going to help for that he goes
well eighty deserved it you know like
that's how I felt like in my mind it's
like I always am trying to make it funny
alright it's very way on so that to
remove the he and the her is just to
further humiliate the the people that
have taken the wrong path until you know
the bathroom it looks very transgender
it's like this this beast with like
breasts and I don't know I I just think
it's just a further degrade humanity you
I mean you go to the doctor and you say
look doctor I want you to cut off my my
arm my hand they're gonna send you to
see a shrink you say look you got a
perfectly good foot doctor I need you to
cut it off you see where I'm going right
but now you aren't but you come to the
doctor today in today's day and age and
now you're going to end up you know
cutting this vital healthy organ made
for procreation and you know and now you
you end up getting an okay a young child
gets an okay he actually gets him to
toss strong blockers to go to the derma
develop the natural development and you
know there was so many cases now there's
there's is taken away their traumatizing
and taking away family it's just all
dates it all stems from holy matrimony
you know mother father child it's like
they're always
trying to break that so when you have
these children thinking about this Lance
Armstrong took hormones to be a better
bicyclist as a bicyclist and he was
punished for that now a child takes
hormones to be a girl and they're
celebrated like think about how twisted
that is where you know a bicyclist takes
a hormone to be a faster bicyclist and
that is cheating and I understand that
that's bad but the world demeans them
and says you lance armstrong you're a
terrible man you're a liar but yet a
five-year-old said you know the parents
say Oh Lance is really Lucinda and and
now there's somehow a hero and that's
because it's satanic they're trying to
remove the masculine from the boy and
the feminine from the girl so that
they'll never be able to have a family
and that's because the family will
protect them and it's like that's always
what it is it's a hatred of people wow
this is just amazing what we come to
there was a statements I heard before
that the greatest trick that the devil
played on mankind is is convincing him
he didn't exist so we've had I've had
many people I've talked to when they've
sieves a lot of the evil that's being
perpetuated in the world this by itself
people who covered up their natural
belief in God Almighty when they have
seen all of this evil this convinced
them now before if they didn't it wasn't
apparent over to them that there is
these satanic dark forces out there now
when they see all this evil and I could
see wow there is this this these demonic
devils out there now that obviously had
the next if there's a devil there
obviously is a creator one creator out
there and this opened up people's minds
you know because now you just can't
house this is just this is we see who's
the perpetuator of all this evil and
then when people don't have a good moral
compass they don't have a sincere
genuine connection with their creator
and now everything's arbitrary
everything goes it's you know that you
have you ever heard that game back in
the day people play that game what would
you do for a million yeah yeah yeah now
I do like almost nothing
I don't I don't you know that whole
thing of like what would you for a
million dollars it's it's such a
Faustian deal you ever read up Faust
where it's like the devil gives you a
Ferrari but no gasoline
you know eternal life but a life
sentence in prison where it's just
that's always how it is it's always like
whatever you ask for he'll give you but
with no ability to feel it or be
grateful or it like you know it's almost
like McDonald's food like you can eat it
but you'll never be full like you the
devil's water doesn't quench your thirst
and and it's like it almost is like the
more time goes on the more we're being
showed evil on a higher and higher level
you know it starts off very subtle and
then it just keeps going until it's just
someone stabbing a pregnant woman and
eating the baby and being like do you
believe yet you know it just keeps
escalating until people just finally go
yeah man I don't know what this is that
isn't what I signed up for have you had
experience talking to any people who
claim to be a theist and how do you talk
with them what kind of arguments what do
you what do you say uh yeah I mean I
know people that I usually it breaks
down to what we're talking about in the
beginning that Oxford study you were
referencing where human beings are
designed to believe like no one's
actually an atheist in my opinion you
know people that believe in nothing just
believe in anything like for me atheist
is typically the person that one week
it's veganism the next week it's
CrossFit the next week it's some
celebrity the next week it's like Atkins
died it's like if you don't have the
foundation of truth you just believe
whatever fad comes in your lap and
that's why the the controllers really
really like atheists because atheists
are they have that point in them so
they're always looking to fill it with
whatever nonsense they're trying to sell
or it's like chia pet you know or like
this scam or this war this thing and you
know if you buy this you'll be full and
it's just you're never fully so no one's
really an atheist I've never met an
atheist in my life you
met a million people that say you know
they believe in science we're spinning
uncontrollably in an infinite void and
this is all just material and we all
just came from bacteria that just kept
banging for billions of years but like
they're not really atheist because they
always believed in in something you know
they put their faith in science that's
clearly wrong so that means they've
deified science where they're like you
know ask basic questions where it's like
how does sexual selection get somebody
on a dorsal fin like isn't that like
millions of years of just extreme you
know like someone having a hunchback and
like weird flash on their back look
how's that sexually out its agent
they're like how dare you and I'm like
oh I'm talking to someone who believes
in a god it's just the material
God you know I just think they all
believe in in the devil is God that's
who they see goddess mm-hmm
when I was uh interviewing people on the
streets where I was talking to you about
about survival and have you have you
been you've been to Europe right have
you been to your yeah oh yeah make sure
you put if you're if you're gonna visit
put aside ival and I'm sure our brother
out there Orhan and some others would
love to you know host you for a few days
if you want to visit Sarajevo so keep
that in your back of your mind I thought
I'd mentioned that yeah so when I was
there I did that interview and we were
talking about these bubble Carelli and
they did a record called pact with the
devil
and I remember sometime after that
someone sent a message saying hey thank
you guys for going over this I didn't
realize this and then they sent some
pictures with these guys having and
that's my question to you is like some
tattoos with someone I something with
the 1i it's what's up with this one huh
that's uh that's that New World Order
Satan stuff it's not on our dollar bills
and stuff it's like I think it's the
same thing it's the same thing yeah it's
the Eye of Horus it's it goes back to
this weird Egyptian and called his stuff
where the one eye that's why so many
celebrities are always doing like this
stuff have you guys I've
I've kind of tried to learn that stuff
but I really it always just keeps
spinning around I used to do a bit where
I'm like yeah I'm a 360 degree Mason I
just did a circle and ended up where I
started
where's like every time I think I'm
learning something it just keeps sending
me down more nonsense red herrings where
all I really figured out about the one
eyes that it's some sort of a cultist
esoteric deity that they worship I don't
really understand it you know it kind of
reminds me of in the land of the blind
the man with one eyes King yeah where
it's like it's almost like they're
trying to make the whole world blind so
that this feeble you know this feeble
deity is king and then it's also know
the eye sore on and on Lord of the Rings
is very symbolic of that where you just
have the one hi it's it's getting all
the orcs to find all the good guys and
stuff you something going on wise I
don't like it when you when you look
deeper you see like Alastair crowds be
is it he wrote a book and many people
uses as a reference where he talks about
you know connection with evil spirits
and devils and whatnot and and you see a
lot of these people connecting to him
and then they go into the this realm you
know yeah I think they're just liars I
was like oh I've never read Aleister
Crowley's writings because I I don't
want to let any of his words in yeah but
I analyzed his life and it's impossible
like you know one minute like one week
he's in Egypt the next week he's in
Japan studying Shintoism and then a
month later he's like being you know
honored by Tibetans and Buddhism I'm
like oh this is just a liar like a lot
of these people I think are just
perverts and weirdos and they just make
up this neverending lies that people
think they're special and give them
money and sex I really think that some
of these people are just like Aleister
Crowley his the timeline of his life is
such nonsense that in those days with
that before like airplane travel he's
saying that he's in one continent and
then acts like a week later getting
honored by Buddha
and so as soon as they spot someone is a
liar I just throw it all away and I'm
like oh so nothing he says matters you
know I think a lot of that satanic stuff
just has to do a trauma where they do
these rituals and they do this abuse so
that children just become broken and
enslaved to them but are in that I think
they're just total liar Zinn scumbags
yeah these are 100% Liars these are
these you say people who work with
devils who work with we have we have
what's called this term the jinn you've
heard of it did this is like the this is
the unseen world of the of the devils so
now you have people like that who work
you know who lie and deceive people but
then it's sad that you have people in
this rap industry in the movie industry
and Hollywood industry many people who
go ahead and then they go ahead and they
use as a reference for whatever they end
up you know why would you go ahead and
take any anything from a liar like this
from a book like this you follow me it's
because there's no atheist it's like
you'll have these people I would and
they think that they've outsmarted the
system and they're like making money and
doing stuff and deep in their heart they
still worship yeah and so they'll find a
book rather it's you know the right once
you know like Holy Bible Koran you know
I like books that will send even though
there's differences obviously between
Bible and Koran at least they're both in
the same category of V God versus a
nonsense book you know or Scientology or
any of these things that are like well
we'll fill that void for you and you
know you're known by your fruits and I
think the best way to that I usually can
tell if somebody's path is righteous or
if it's nonsense is like does their
religion or beliefs make them a liar and
someone like Aleister Crowley or one of
these all these one-eye weirdos they
always just end up lying all the time I
always just end up misrepresenting
themselves and using Talmudic logic and
loopholes and like you know I didn't
kill the man he starved to death but I
did tie him up teehee
and I'm like so you're a liar so that
your path is clearly false and I think
that a lot of these people they human
beings require worship where that that's
how we're made so rather or not it's to
God or to the material or to your own
selfish pleasures and you know the
Aleister Crowley people they all say do
as thou wilt yes would they say yeah so
you know it's a word Trek where do as
doubt well so many of these idiots think
because the way Satanists a lot of times
work is in contract law they like to
sneak in trick so they say do as that
will shall be the entirety to law and
people like oh that means I'll do what I
want but then if you put a different
enunciation on the words do as thou wilt
or do as thou wilt means like do as
you're told you know do as thou will do
as thou is Wilt do is like the devil
wills you and you see that you see like
like that woman that you were talking
about that like mime like eight or baby
it's like at first it's do as doubt well
then she was probably like just doing
whatever made her happy and didn't think
about anybody and then it's do as thou
wilt yeah which means do it you're told
and that's when they jump into this
demonic world that we can't really
understand where it's like why why would
someone hurt a kid or why would someone
hate a baby you know I got that that's
that's the next level as do as that will
so like do like it starts as do what you
want and then just like the donkeys in
Pinocchio they're their ears start
growing and their nose you start crying
and and then it's do as you're tall
donkey yeah and and the ultimate
enslavement is from Satan you know it's
very I won't hold you out too much
longer there's a couple more questions
but finishing off with this one it's
interesting because that's exactly what
the motto is do as ad I will so
basically follow your lust your desires
your passions hedonism debauchery all of
that stuff but going away from your will
be done right submitting your will so
instead of do a stout will no submitting
your will to God doing what God the
creator Rob wants me to do it's totally
done antithesis the opposite
it right so you make your now you make
yourself yeah if you do God's will it's
like everybody benefits if you do your
own will you enter the jungle because
it's math it's like okay if what you
want goes against one that someone
else's will and they get to do what they
want
whoever's stronger and as a bigger stick
wins
welcome to luciferianism you know where
it's like the Light Bearer
the light bringer it's like okay well
what I want is that house and someone's
like well I want that house and now you
just have perpetual war versus when you
do gods bidding you know you all can
enter this this realm of love and peace
and harmony and logos where it's like
but when you when you're serving your
own desires someone else has the under
the law of who separatism they have the
right to pursue their desires so when
those desires cross you just beat each
other to death and it's like that's
awful no yeah that's that's interesting
because then you follow your desires and
you make yourself into a deity right you
suck yourself as a God next to God yeah
life's just real quick just on that
point because that's a great point
you're a DD but you're insignificant cuz
you're not really a DDL that's why
iPhone iPad iPod all of it
lowercase I that's why it's the bitten
apple you know Steve Jobs his name is
basically Eve job you know it's like he
has a bitten apple and the lowercase I
is Satanism where it's like I like you
will be the center but it's a lowercase
yeah because you're not God and so
that's the hell that people enter with
the bitten apple absolutely yes you can
yep you know buddy you're you cannot be
a deity you cannot be a god but people
just want to be that just because you
mentioned now Steve Jobs you know that
he actually the developer of all these
devices he actually restricted or kept
his kids away from them oh yeah he knew
how bad they were
you know how these dudes are just drug
dealers on a massive waffle what about
the TI you know TI I don't know TI I've
heard of them are bunch of I now know
what do you think it seems at one point
it seems like the you have what you have
we call this lead-up Leda is called this
protective jealousy it's kind of looked
down upon nowadays but you have
protection protective gel healthy
protective jealousy over your wife your
children a man steps up you know to you
know the guard the home to guard his
family now this man this rapper he TI he
was doing a virginity check every you
know year or something and but it's
interesting now he he wants his daughter
to be a virgin right nowadays it's not
cool to be a virgin yeah but at the same
time you see a lot of these people you
know making these videos you know
degrading the women and whatnot but I
just mentioned this point because you
still have these you know men you still
have these some of these good qualities
but it's been clouded that's their moral
compass that it just needs to be really
polished you know oh yeah a hundred
percent or inside that that is that is a
great quality in a man as you want to
protect their his daughter did you hear
about did you hear about this news
report that everyone came down he was
about the virginity test what has died
at hymen he was aren't about yeah yeah
yeah we're it's not but that's the
upside down where it's like in the rap
world you can throw dollars at women and
dump champagne on them and then oh make
it rain on a young make it right yet
your daughter's virginity you're seen as
a bag well that's the upside down it's
the yeses no no is yes high school
marriage is slavery slavery is freedom
it's like once you spot it it's pretty
obvious where I just like you know
that's I like I've tuned myself at this
point to be able to just be like oh
that's the upside down that's the devil
like you know protecting your child is
bad
but yet dumping champagne on around on a
yacht is great it's like you know what
all these parents are celebrated for
having trans kids but yet TI wants his
daughter to be saved for marriage it's
like it's just nonsense yeah as I was
saying they make it rain you heard
that's that statement of course yeah
it's just crazy all right I'll just
start asking one more thing we are I got
I was really really surprised how people
I remember one one person making a
comment talking about how much hate they
had fear and everything after they
watched I don't know how much feedback
you got also on this it was just so
surprising how just that one Pro episode
me and you that show we did that video
we did together how many people were
affected in a positive way in a positive
light yeah like just people speaking
their mind truthfully without like weird
agendas is very healing no matter what
it just always is good that's why I just
I enjoyed our talk and I got a lot of
great feedback from it I'm sure you got
a lot of great feedback from it it's
just like that's how you kill these fake
constructed boogeyman in your hearts you
know because we're from the time we're
kids we're given these thoughts and
feelings and images of things that just
aren't real and when you just see two
guys talking about you know what's going
on in the world and food and marriage
and children it's like it helped it just
helps people it just helps their hearts
you know I I made it I showed you my
little my little tribe there with my
sheeps and my little calves I sent a
video I made a video and if you got a
chance it got to you but I yeah so you
got to see so so where I'm at but
hopefully God will in the future we can
meet in person sometime I was really
pleasure talking with you I as always
enjoyed it we have some good things to
share thank you so much you as well my
friend talk soon okay take care brother
peace alright peace news well